Most people think they know all about the
most famous volcanic disaster ever, but the
factual story is even more incredible than
the fiction.
This August 24th is the 1936th anniversary
of the violent erasure of Pompeii from the
shores of the Tyrrhenian Sea.
I've been to Pompeii, it's beautiful, but
it's also amazingly expansive.
The city of Pompeii is three square kilometers,
and excavation has been ongoing since it was
rediscovered in 1748.
As archaeology continues, modern scientific
techniques are teaching us more and more about
that infamous day.
Around lunchtime on August 24, 79 CE, Mount
Vesuvius exploded.
Eyewitness Pliny the Younger (whose grandfather,
Pliny the Elder was a military officer stationed
in the region) wrote, "a cloud of unusual
size and appearance," shot into the air from
Vesuvius, reminding him of an umbrella pine
tree.
At its' height on that day, Vesuvius' column
reached 27 miles (43km) into the sky before
branching out, and raining ash and pumice
stones on the 2,000 Pompeians who hadn't already
fled the city.
The eruption caught people by surprise, many
fleeing the city after that initial explosion
but before the city was completely buried
by ash.
But from surviving records, we know there
were signs something bad was coming.
Fish were floating dead in the rivers, wells
were drying up, and the vines on the slopes
of the volcano inexplicably dried up; not
to mention increasingly violent and regular
earthquakes were hitting the region.
Today we know, before volcanoes erupt, they
swell slightly as the pressurized magma bulb
rises through the earth, like a massive zit…
Eventually, the mountain can begin to leak
noxious gases, which might have contributed
to the death of the plants.
Measurements before the eruption of Pu'u O'o
on Kilauea in 1983 found 150 tons of Sulfur
dioxide was released from the mountain per
day!
People who fled Pompeii on August 24th would
have escaped the coming disaster, but after
midnight on August 25th, between three and
six massive superheated pyroclastic surges
-- like an avalanche, but of rock, dust and
volcanic gas travelling 100 kph (62mph) -- slammed
into the city… burying Pompeii (and the
people who remained) in volcanic dust for
many hundreds of years.
Looking at the distribution and type of debris
in the ash layers, scientists estimated the
velocity and power of the 79 CE explosion
of Vesuvius at 165,000 tons of debris per
second, with 84 rocks per square yard per
minute raining down on the cities and temperatures
reaching 482 F (250C).
A 2013 study in Nature Communications found
a mass extinction event in the lower Cretaceous
caused by a volcano resulted in exceptional
fossil preservation, and Pompeii plays out
something similar.
If volcanic ash gets wet, it hardens like
cement, preserving anything trapped inside.
Over time, the clothing and soft tissues of
the Pompeians decayed, and today, their dry,
fragile bones and jewelry are all that survives.
Some of the most famous artifacts from Pompeii
aren't the superb frescoes, houses, and even
bread in the ovens of the bakeries… but
casts of the Pompeians themselves.
In 1777 excavators discovered an air pocket
in the shape of a body, and in 1864 (almost
100 years later!) the director of excavations
found a special mix of plaster of Paris which
could be poured INTO the cavities to mold
out a body, revealing the heartbreaking detail
of the last moments of these people.
The wrong mixture of plaster can damage the
delicate remains, so of the 1150 bodies found,
only 100 have been cast.
Today Pompeii is a UNESCO world heritage site,
and now feeling the pains of exposure to pollution,
light, weathering, and water damage.
After heavy rains in some buildings in the
city collapsed.
Even after preservation in volcanic ash for
over 1600 years, we're losing Pompeii to the
elements.
Today, Vesuvius is the only active volcano
on the European continent and 700,000 people
live in "death zones" immediately surrounding
the mountain, ironically, they were drawn
there because the ash and lava flows emitted
by volcanoes create some of the most fertile
soil on earth.
After a volcano erupts, the rock fragment
particles ejected are called tephra, and over
time tephra breaks down thanks to chemical
interaction from the atmosphere, resulting
in that super-rich soil.
And it's only a matter of time until Vesuvius
hits it again.